welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Marvel's the Eternals is the
next big mystery coming up on the MCU
calendar a lineup of less familiar names
promising to revolutionize the Marvel
mythology maybe even the surprise
game-changer for phase 4 that guardians
of the galaxy was and years past all the
details we've been learning about these
characters and movie's plot and the
limit eventual showing the movies
production design are starting to paint
a picture for how exactly the Eternals
could be the key to Marvel's future has
the Eternals they've been on earth for
thousands of years walking amongst us
throughout the history of the MCU events
that we know so what have they been
doing
why don't we seen them yet well I
actually think some clues from past MCU
films have set up their existence and
we're gonna see how their secret history
will establish the biggest game change
of it they'd see the mutants engage my
theories right in ruins or phase for now
I decided to make this video after
pitching a version of this concept on
rogue theory and everyone loved it so
much I got awarded the Golden rogue and
now people are requesting it as its own
breakdown and uh you might want to check
out that epic episode of you haven't yet
but I get I agree let's dig into this ok
the Eternals massive casting includes
these super-powered immortals who date
back to ancient times figures that
various human cultures adapted into
their mythologies kind of like the ones
hinted at in spider-man far from home
versions of them exists across our
mythologies turns out the myths are real
like Thor Laura was a myth and now I
study him in my physics class but at the
center of this plot will be Kit
Harington as Dayne Whitman the Marvel
Comics Whitman is a scientist who takes
on his ancestral mantle as the hero
Black Knight here it sounds like Whitman
will be an archaeologist who discovers
the secret of the Eternals like male
Nanjiani now putting the male and
Camille he's playing the eternal King go
and he send an interview that kinko is
disguising himself as a bollywood movie
star and for all of these characters I
believe ancestry will be the important
theme of Marvel phase 4 where do you
come from where do you go we need to
come from Jack King do the events of
Avengers endgame and maybe a secretive
Asian plot will leave human society a
little paranoid over who among them they
can trust like some members of society
are Scrolls in disguise so everyone
could
scroll while it's going on those snobby
Cree from hala are dispersing propaganda
that the scrolls just like that mad
Titan Thanos who you know wreaked havoc
upon the universe they all descended
from this bloodline known as the deviant
gene genetic aberration from the ancient
experiments of the godless with all the
normal folks in the MC would be like
grimace uses magic jewels to turn all my
favorite dusk so I guess anything's
possible
various artwork that has been released
for the Eternals film has shown
depictions of these Celestials which
were first teased in the MCU with that
east on the searcher cameo and guardians
of the galaxy nowhere being a severed
celestial head and the fact that ego
himself was a celestial there are the
ancient gods who created both the
Eternals in their enemies the deviants
so in a society panicking over this
whole genetic history bombshell enter
archaeologist Dane Wittman who studies
the ebony blade which you know like
touching old stuff often does in nerd
stories this triggers a flashback he
goes back to ancient times the Sumerians
the Egyptians and among the ancient
immortal sea witnesses is Kingo whom he
recognizes as a modern day bollywood
superstar kind of like how real-life
immortals like Keanu Reeves and Nic Cage
show up in old timey photographs cover's
blown cameos should have kept your shirt
on now this movie is being described as
a love story between Whitman and Jimmy
chin as Cersei sounds like Cersei has
been assigned to erase Whitman's
memories but as happens in the comics
often in life they fall in love
I expect the story because something
like this is Hercules or Twilight you
know with ancient and mortals pressuring
the lover I don't care if you love him
he's immortal it'll expose the soul and
disrupt the ancient balance so that's
lobotomize him so he knows nothing these
high and mighty eternals like Richard
Madden is Icarus Salma Hayek is a Jacke
Angelina Jolie is thena
they'll be the antagonists box two
blinded by hatred of their eternal foes
the deviants I think the big
game-changing twist is that as we saw
with the not actually evil scrolls these
deviant others are actually decent
beings misunderstood like Team Jacob
they're not evil they're just different
and always losing their shirts
put your clothes off and the whole
us-versus-them mindset that the Kree
inherited and their wars with the scroll
actually dates back to the Eternals
versus deviant wars of ancient times and
I believe this twist is actually going
mask' deeper to his one that will be
revealed late in the film maybe in the
post-credits scene now I'll admit I
don't wake up every day with this face
the event fresh especially after a long
night of piecing together these clues
are Marvel set photos and Marvel
Instagram posts big help with waking me
up so that I can know all these things
at you is bang energy and thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video a perk
in a bang is 16 ounces that's right no
wimpy 12 ounce cans here contains 300
milligrams of caffeine it's sugar-free
it has zero calories yes it tastes great
candy apple crisp there's over 20
different flavors to choose from this
one yeah candy apple crisp lotte easy on
my lips but also on my tongue cuz my
lips don't have them taste good
yeah it might cause you to burst in a
song if you're weird mmm I think my lips
do with taste buds now check out bang on
Instagram you can get 25% off your order
at bang - energy calm when you use the
code new rock stars 25 there you can buy
cans of bang energy including their
sweet cp2 coffee flavors you can also
get clothing fitness supplements all
kinds of stuff to be your best bangin
itself and thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using the code new
rock stars 25 and a follow the inventor
of being on instagram at bang energy dot
CEO if these superpower Eternals are
hiding in plain sight in the modern era
of the MCU discretely helping the good
guys in battles and preventing various
disasters behind the scenes may be
helping contain disasters that we did go
through but keeping them from getting
even worse then the evolutionary
descendants of the deviants may also be
alive in the present day I'm not talking
about those shape-shifting Scrolls their
deviance from other worlds off earth I
think the deviants from this world the
Terran deviants will go by a new name
and what's another word we use on this
planet for genetic deviations mutations
yes the modern-day deviants in the MCU I
believe are mutants they live in secret
they hide in plain sight they do
everything they can to contain their
mutant abilities they fear that they'll
be outed and caged as freaks
experimented on by the government
perhaps this government experimentation
on mutants has already been going on
with secret programs like project Exodus
everything from projects Pegasus
exhibition Goliath it has been an
alternate name for Weapon X in the MCU
now in the Marvel Comics this isn't
exactly the history of the X gene but it
is one of those reinterpreted elements
that Marvel fans aren't really that
sacred about imagine
by giving two related tinkering with
this because really I just think there's
a great opportunity here for Marvel to
retcon a backstory of this universe for
both the Eternals and the mutants that
links them both to these Celestials so
yes if Marvel wants to use the Eternals
to establish mutants in this universe
just imagine a post-credits scene that
follows the mutating deviant gene
through generation after a generation of
human history until it arrives to the
present day in the blood of a lone
hitchhiker in the Canadian wilderness
climbs up into a truck shakes the snow
out of his sideburns the name's Logan
Wolverine what do you think will be the
big twist of the Eternals comment down
below and for more unfiltered thoughts
in the MCU join our discord server by
becoming a patron today at patreon.com
slash new rock stars follow me at Avis
follow new rock stars and subscribe to
know rock stars or breakdowns of
everything Marvel thanks for watching
bye evolution moves leaps forward every
thousand years vara blah blah make it so
[Music]